o nem quem quer fazer rapidamente é
entender a que vocês acharam do nosso
evento do evento tão bem estruturado
pelo toda essa equipe da idéia da
comunicação social e dentro do contexto
onde a gente quis encaixar em algum
momento né
foi ora se o feedback é tão importante
para todo e qualquer evento todo e
qualquer a ação acho que todo mundo
gosta de ouvir e receber críticas né
e na educação a mesma idéia
só que por incrível que pareça por
exemplo imagine umas duas situações
patéticas
primeiro uma linha de produção qualquer
aí eu estou montando veículos estão
montando caminhões e ao final da minha
no processo produtivo de caminhões
eu descubro que uma um veículo está
conforme nós gostaríamos que eles
tivessem a imagem que eu fizesse isso
depois virá o psb como tá bom
volta-se veicular o começo da linha e
faz ele passar por toda linha de novo a
não pensar que isso não tem muito
sentido não tem muita lógica não é uma
medida mais inteligente
imagine agora que a gente tenha um
doente um paciente médico
ele precisa de um tratamento hospitalar
ele passa se durante um ano por um
sofrimento muito grande por um
tratamento médico muito grande e ao
final do do ano
o médico que anima chica fala olha
realmente você não respondeu ao processo
o paciente vai perguntar poxa então quem
quer fazer simplesmente vai fazer esse
ano todo o processo balsinhas de novo
porque quem sabe assim o seu corpo
começa a responder a isso
o paciente vai passar todo outro ano com
o processo idêntico ao que aconteceu
uma das palestrantes poderia falar a
mesma coisa diferente a dieta imagine
que eu tenho um alguém que está fazendo
uma reeducação alimentar qualquer
balanço nutricional lista eo
nutricionista diz kobra roxa
olha você tem um problema o que você
está comendo não está fazendo bem pra
você ea pessoa pergunta então que o faça
mudar o que se fala não claro que não
vai continuar comendo exatamente você
sempre com o meu que tem que mudar o seu
corpo você tem que mudar o seu corpo do
gol tem que aprender a reagir a esse
tipo de alimento
tudo isso soa muito absurdo né mas é
isso que a gente faz a educação
freqüentemente eu tenho um aluno meu
aluno passa pelos meus processos todos e
quaisquer variados a ao chegar ao final
do processo falou bicho não deu certo
vamos lá pro começo e tenta de novo eu
faço um aluno passar pelo mesmo processo
que da primeira vez não funcionou quem
me garante que vai funcionar na segunda
vez
o que mudou no processo mesmo aluno
mesmo professor o mesmo não tem sentido
tudo vai continuar tendo os mesmo
resultados
então é dentro desse contexto que a
gente começou a repensar alguns
parâmetros né e eles cometeram um erro
tirar o meu tempo vocês são loucos e
então pensando rapidamente falou olha eu
preciso ter processos de feedback ao
longo de todo o meu processo de
educacional ao longo de cada aula tem
que saber o que está acontecendo eu não
posso esperar um mês dois meses um ano
para descobrir como o aluno não atingiu
o que eu gostaria
temos um problema esse processo não é um
processo bem pensado
esse processo tem falhas e anos falou
aqui das crianças eles fazem isso com as
crianças muito bem
eles acompanham as crianças dia-a-dia
ora ora em um momento em que esquece
como faz isso pelo menos eu sou
professor universitário agentes eu como
faz isso bem então a foi toda s speech
aqui pra gente falar olha a preciso
utilizar métodos
instrumentos que me permitam verificar o
meu processo enquanto o processo está
acontecendo enquanto eu consigo de
alguma maneira atuar nesse processo e
não esperar que tudo dê errado então
esses cliques que vocês receberam é uma
dessas ferramentas que a gente tem
utilizado em algumas aulas não é única e
muito de longe não é mais importante é
uma das ferramentas é o que a gente faz
muitas aulas é o aluno fica com clique
eu vou ao longo da utilizando um clique
para descobrir se o aluno está
aprendendo ou não ele está captando ou
não os conceitos que eu tenho
apresentado pra ele né
é o famoso você entendeu só que agora
tecnológico é anônimo e eu consigo
contabilizar contar saber quantas vezes
o aluno responder ou não ou seja
conseguir transformar aquele monte de de
dados e informações úteis para gerenciar
o meu processo de aprendizagem
bem é dentro desse contexto que a gente
vai utilizar os cliques para vocês
avaliarem o evento
então a não tem mistério vocês vão
simplesmente apertar em um número de 1 a
4 módulos é de 35 chateados de 1 a 4
para muito ruim com em bom ou ótimo para
cada uma das perguntas são só cinco
perguntas se não me falha a memória
certo então podem fazer aí qual a sua
avaliação sobre o processo de inscrição
e credenciamento certo então um muito
bem em 21 em 3 com quatro pódios em 23
acho que todo mundo já está voltando eo
legal é isso é preciso explicar como a
coisa funciona intuitivamente as pessoas
já fazem rock
ok bem aqui o resultado então em sala de
aula consigo saber exatamente o
resultado em casa segundo vocês são os
fofos são muito educados
então vocês votaram 57% falaram que é
ótimo o nosso processo de inscrição e
credenciamento bem mas podemos ir para a
outra pergunta qual a sua avaliação
sobre a divulgação do evento ok então um
de novo muito ruim
2 ruim 3 bom 4 ótimo então 34 40 estão
alinhados e todas as informações e eu
posso consultar ao longo da minha aula
posso consultar depois da minha alma
possa utilizar essas informações para
gerenciar o processo que agora se
dividiu em 8% em 16 foram em 33% bom e
13% acham seus começaram a ficarem mais
sinceros muito bom eles
isso acontece em sala de aula no então
esse tipo de coisa há pessoas comemoram
acreditar que elas podem realmente falar
a verdade é o que nos interessa falar
realmente o que elas pensam
então com a avaliação sobre estoques
nessa noite conteúdo e os pixels dos
apresentadores os palestrantes
novo 1 2 3 ou 4 72 então 1% muito em
três ruins e 31% bom 38%
ótimo seguindo ainda para algumas
perguntas perguntas é qual a sua
avaliação sobre as intervenções
artísticas 1 2 3 ou 4
fé 405% há muito ruim 6% ruim 29% bom e
35% muito ótimo né
na verdade e por último se não me engano
são 56 na verdade é a penúltima você
recomendaria o tex para outras pessoas
um dois três ou quatro na verdade o
nível de remuneração que você daria né
é muito ruim você não daria jeito nenhum
em falar é muito ruim 2 ruim acho que o
bom e hoje não sei se é recomendado
ok
pelo menos recomendar todo estão
recomendando e agora essa sim por último
estava mentindo até então você votaria
voltarei a participar de um táxi e b
edições futuras
então muito bom dois muito em 31 bom 4
ótimo mesmo a ideia bom e ótimo
significa que se você votaria em 1 e 2
acho que não você não votaria
muitas pessoas de se chegar até 70 agora
disparado
ok
então 2%
acho que não recomendaria o rasto
recomendaríamos bem era essa idéia essa
pequena a pílula que a gente queria
mostrar dentro do processo o que é e eu
pessoalmente adorei a ocs achei
fantástico os inspiradores
muito obrigado e agora é preciso esperar
o andré toda a deixa para ele mas ele
não está aparecendo aqui obrigado